[Música]
cuando yo era pequeña mi juego favorito
era saltar a la comba y me costó
aprender de hecho fui de las últimas de
mis amigas en aprender sabéis cuándo la
comba está girando y tú tienes que
saltar y meterte pues yo me tropezaba me
caía pero al final conseguí aprender y
siempre que tenía oportunidad yo quería
jugar a saltar a la comba todos hemos
sido niños verdad todos hemos vivido esa
primera etapa que tan importante es para
nuestro desarrollo como personas la
infancia
y ahora que hablamos de infancia os voy
a invitar a que por un momento pensé es
en infancia no tenéis que decir nada en
voz alta
solamente observad qué ideas qué
pensamientos qué imágenes vienen a
vuestra cabeza al pensar en infancia
y os voy a contar una historia ana es
una chica de 22 años es una chica
inteligente y muy capaz está estudiando
un posgrado y tiene muchísimas ganas de
incorporarse al mundo laboral tiene
proyectos ilusiones y un grandísimo
talento para el dibujo anna es una chica
amiga de sus amigos que siempre que
puede se escapa al monte a hacer
senderismo porque le encanta el contacto
con la naturaleza a nada lo tiene todo
para ser feliz tiene toda la vida por
delante y sin embargo esta es su tercera
depresión grave y su segundo intento de
suicidio
y es que ana cuando era pequeña ella
jugaba a las maestras a ella le
encantaba poner a todos sus muñequitos
en filas y jugar a darles clases algunas
veces le tocaba a los primitos hacer de
alumnos ya desde pequeña apuntaba
maneras con esto del dibujo y siempre
iba con una cajita de colores
pintarrajeando por ahí pero anna jugaba
a otro tipo de juegos jugaba un juego en
el que un familiar adulto cuando nadie
miraba se iba con ella a una habitación
a solas y cerraba la puerta
anna sufrió abuso sexual cuando era
pequeña
y probablemente abuso no estaba entre
las ideas que han venido a vuestra
cabeza al pensar en infancia solemos
tener la infancia asociada a niños
jugando riendo el colegio un parque los
que sois papás de niños pequeños
probablemente las tareas del día a día
lo que cuesta a veces que los niños se
vayan a la cama su hora abuso no es algo
que nos venga a la cabeza y sin embargo
uno de cada cinco niños sufre abuso
sexual en europa uno de cada cinco
esto significa que todos los que estamos
aquí hoy conocemos a alguien que ha
sufrido está sufriendo o sufrirá abuso
sexual infantil
más aún esto significa que de entre
todos los que estamos hoy aquí algunos
hemos sufrido abuso sexual
una de cada cuatro niñas es víctima de
este terrible hecho y uno de cada siete
niños
sé que lo que os estoy contando es una
realidad dura es una realidad difícil de
escuchar me queda un dato duro más que
daros y es que se estima que el 85 por
ciento de los casos de abuso sexual
infantil ocurren en el entorno más
cercano al menor es decir el abuso es
cometido por alguien a quien el niño
quiere en que el niño confía y es que
precisamente la confianza es una de las
bazas que tiene el abusador la confianza
y el secreto y el secreto puede adoptar
dos formas puede adoptar la forma de
amenaza si le cuentas esto a alguien te
van a castigar
o puede adoptar la forma de amor este es
nuestro juego especial entre tú y yo
porque tú eres mi niño mi niña especial
y que es abuso
a buses esto
imaginad que este folio representa la
inocencia el desarrollo sano de un niño
o de una niña
esto es abuso sexual
y estas sus consecuencias por mucho que
yo quiera este folio no va a volver a
estar como estaba
el abuso sexual es una herida para toda
la vida una herida que en el mejor de
los casos la persona buscará ayuda la
encontrará y conseguirá reconstruir su
vida en el peor de los casos será un
niño o una niña roto que se convertirá
en un adulto roto y es que para abusar
de un niño no hace falta ni siquiera
tocarle si yo me siento al lado de un
niño y me pongo a ver pornografía con él
o con ella porque me excita sexualmente
estoy abusando de ese niño cuando
estamos furtivamente en un vestuario de
un polideportivo porque nos excita
sexualmente estoy abusando de ese niño
si yo le pido a un niño oa una niña que
se desnude para mí yo no le estoy
tocando pero estoy abusando de él o de
ella abuso sexual infantil es cualquier
acto intencionado de obtener placer
sexual utilizando a un niño y digo bien
utilizando a un niño
el abusador es un adulto o una persona
superior al niño en edad o que tiene
algún tipo de poder sobre él o es
superior en madurez
sé que hoy estoy hablando de una
realidad dura y difícil de escuchar
conocerla conocer sus consecuencias es
lo que nos llevó a mí y al equipo con el
que trabajo para llevar a cabo el
proyecto que os voy a contar esta tarde
somos un equipo de cuatro doctoras en
psicología hay una doctor en medicina de
la universidad de málaga que hemos visto
demasiadas veces en nuestra práctica
clínica las consecuencias del abuso
sexual infantil porque os he dado cifras
que son difíciles de escuchar que hacen
a uno plantearse muchas cosas pero es
que detrás de esas cifras hay vidas
truncadas por eso es el año pasado nos
pusimos manos a la obra y comenzamos el
proyecto corazonada creando conciencia
sobre el abuso sexual infantil lo que
pretendemos con este proyecto es en
primer lugar prevenir el abuso sexual
infantil en segundo lugar que la
sociedad tome conciencia sin alarmismos
sin entrar en paranoias simplemente es
saber que esta realidad existe y que
tenemos que prestarle atención y en
tercer lugar lo que
es que la sociedad esté preparada
preparada para responder a los niños a
las niñas que tienen la desgracia de que
esto les ocurra y cómo lo hacemos pues
lo hacemos basándonos en tres pilares el
primero de ellos es la investigación la
mejor forma de cambiar una realidad es
conociendo la es entendiendo bien cómo
funciona el año pasado emprendimos un
estudio que no tiene otro objetivo que
explorar explorar qué sabe la gente
sobre el abuso sexual infantil qué ideas
que mitos qué creencias
recabamos muchísimos datos en españa y
latinoamérica
y en estos momentos ya estamos
desarrollando nuestro primer artículo
científico también estamos llevando a
cabo un segundo estudio donde queremos
profundizar más aún en la incidencia del
abuso sexual infantil
el segundo pilar de nuestro proyecto es
el trabajo con los adultos porque en
definitiva somos nosotros los
responsables de procurar que el mundo
sea lo más seguro posible para los niños
y el tercer pilar son los niños la mejor
forma de reparar algo es evitando que se
rompa y como hacemos todo esto lo
hacemos apelando a lo que es de verdad
mueve al ser humano apelando a la
emoción para ello tenemos una obra de
teatro a la que asisten los pequeños y
los mayores en esta obra de teatro los
pequeños se sumerge en un cuento y a
través de la fantasía de la música del
baile interactuando con los personajes
sin darse cuenta
aprenden aprenden que es abuso sexual
aprenden recursos para evitar que ocurra
y aprenden recursos para en caso de que
ocurra pedir ayuda posteriormente lo que
hacemos son talleres para asegurarnos de
que los recursos se han aprendido bien y
de que si fuera necesario utilizarlos
los niños sabrían ponerlos en práctica
el trabajo con
adultos con los papás las mamás los
educadores
también en esta línea nosotros somos los
responsables de cuidar a los niños es
muy importante que como adultos sepamos
identificar las señales de que el abuso
está ocurriendo y una vez que por
desgracia confirmamos que está
ocurriendo saber actuar lo que queremos
es crear conciencia y entendemos
conciencia como algo inherente al ser
humano algo que lo engloba en su
totalidad por ello utilizamos todo tipo
de técnicas vivenciales utilizamos la
música el movimiento la creatividad la
imagen todo lo que ayude a la persona al
adulto a la adulta a conectar con su
propia emoción para estar preparados
para cuidarse a sí mismo y a su vez
cuidar de ese niño de esa niña porque no
es tan fácil imaginaros imaginaros que
un niño o una niña al que queréis os
cuenta os cuenta que el adulto x
le ha pedido que se desnude en ese
momento somos secuestrados
somos secuestrados por emociones que van
desde el miedo la rabia la impotencia la
culpa la vergüenza y la peor de todas el
bloqueo el bloqueo emocional ocurre
cuando mi emoción es tan dura y tan
intensa que no puedo responder a ella un
adulto bloqueado va a ser un adulto que
no pueda ni responder a su propia
emoción ni responder a ese niño a esa
niña que tanto le necesita por ello
queremos que estemos preparados cuando
va a ser más posible que un adulto se
bloquee cuando el mismo ella misma a su
vez sufrió abuso sexual lo que queremos
en definitiva es que la sociedad tenga
recursos recursos para identificar el
abuso y recursos para responder a él y
recursos para prevenirlo algo así como
un botiquín igual que tenemos un
botiquín para cuando los niños se caen
se hacen un rasguño queremos que los
adultos la sociedad tenga un botiquín de
recursos emocionales porque cuando
tenemos delante
a un niño que ha sufrido abuso sexual lo
que ese niño necesita es saber que no
está solo saber que alguien le escucha
si yo sé cuidar de mí misma puedo
gestionar mi emoción podré cuidar de ese
niño de esa niña y ese niño esa niña a
su vez se convertirá en un adulto en una
adulta capaz de cuidar
esto es
esto es lo que estamos haciendo y antes
de finalizar que ya veo por ahí el reloj
que me tengo que ir os pediría que de
nuevo penséis en infancia sólo un
momento
si en esta segunda ocasión a vuestra
cabeza han venido ideas cómo prevenir
proteger cuidar estar preparados
responder si alguna de estas ideas o
algunas similar ha aparecido entonces
nuestro objetivo uno de ellos con este
con este proyecto se ha conseguido
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]